We have a voicemail number. That number is two one
nine two. David P.. Here's something we heard from
Troy, York. You know, I'm hearing this from a lot
of people, which is basically now that Trump is
gone. Your show is dead, David. It's dead.
You know, just I bet secretly you had to be
rooting for President Trump because I think that
you as a podcast or you are done right. I mean,
if you don't have Trump around, what the hell
is The David Pakman Show going to talk about
and your name, your international funding anymore?
There's no point in funding, which I don't have
programs like you, David Pakman and
Sam, you you guys are done right.
So I don't know why you celebratin were
pushing so hard against Trump when in fact
you're not going to have no conscience.
Right. You know, what's fascinating about
this is that when Obama won and defeated
George W. Bush, I got all the same emails.
You're now on the inside and it's not going
to be there's not going to be nothing to do.
The show quadrupled during Obama raised venture
capital. I mean, it was it was like crazy. The
Obama era was completely crazy for us, but I got
worried. Troy, maybe Troy's on to something here.
Maybe we're done. So I went and looked. And in
the short five day period since the inauguration,
we had live stream views in the millions. We
continue to have one or even two million views
a day on the YouTube channel, even through
the weekend when we normally see a dip.
We added 11000 new YouTube subscribers. And one
of the biggest growth weeks we've ever had on our
Instagram TV channel was the last week during and
since the inauguration. And, you know, the reality
is there are always things going on. Right wing
media is going to be nuts. The next two years.
These Trumpy and right wing elected officials are
going to be nuts. And some of our best performing
clips of the last three months and during the
last three months, Trump did a lot of crazy things
even during the last three months and have been
since the time of Trump's departure. Our coverage
of Lauren Bobert and these other insurrectionists,
the focus group with Republican voters,
one of our top clips, Sean Hannity, claiming
Biden's doing reeducation camps, that this has
been a thing forever. You're circling the drain
now that the winds are changing politically.
And then we grow and we grow and we grow.
And if the last five days are any indication,
the next three months could be really crazy. But,
you know, I'm really glad that through the years
Troy has stuck with us. He seems to love the show
because he knows everything that's going on here.
We will talk to you more on today's bonus
show. Get instant access by becoming a
member at Join Pakman Dotcom. We will talk
about the death of Larry King. We will talk
about the candidacy of Sarah Huckabee, Sanders
for governor of Arkansas and much, much more.
Sign up and get instant
access at. Join Pakman Dotcom.